we also have new information tonight
that you heard John Roberts asked about
about the origins of the corona virus
multiple sources say this may be the
costliest government cover-up of all
time by China the belief now you heard
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs asked
about it that the intelligence was
inconclusive but there is a growing
belief that the covert 19 virus
originated in the Wuhan lab not as a bio
weapon but as China's effort to find and
deal with viruses to show the world
China was as good as or better than the
US on that front it's believed that the
virus was back to human and then human
the human patient zero worked at the lab
went into the population in Wuhan and
the virus quickly spread from there
China according to sources moved quickly
to shut down travel domestically from
Wuhan to the rest of China but did not
immediately stop international flights
from Wuhan these sources say the World
Health Organization was complicit from
the beginning helping China cover its
tracks and that is where we begin
tonight chief White House correspondent
John Roberts starts us off good evening
John you asked about this reporting
tonight got something from the President
and obviously part of the reason why the
president's coming down so hard on the
wh oh yeah there certainly has been a
real change in tone from back in early
February when the president described
the w-h-o is some of the best and the
brightest clearly as this information
begins to develop and is beginning to
gain more traction now among US
officials the president is changing his
mind not only about the w-h-o but about
what happened in China I asked him
directly the information that you and I
had discussed earlier today he didn't
really go down the road of a concrete
answer but he did suggest that he's
looking at that and that that that is
becoming something that the federal
government really wants to know a whole
lot more about breath obviously China
has pushed back about this line the
w-h-o came out publicly and said they
were disappointed in the u.s. decision
but the president appears to be at least
warming up to this line of thinking
really the origins of this virus become
a big big story if it all pans out as
these sources are saying yeah there's
there's no question about that and and
that's why I asked the President to
follow up because he speaks to President
Xi on many many different occasions he
says he's got a great relationship with
him so I asked the president if in any
of the conversations that he has had in
recent months with President Xi or even
going back a couple of years because
there is this reporting which we have
confirmed now that officials from the US
Embassy in Beijing visited this virology
lab the Wuhan Institute of Virology
and were concerned enough about a lack
of safety protocols there that they
cabled back to the State Department that
something should happen on this front to
tighten up their security protocols
that's why I asked the president if he
ever spoke to President Xi about that
the president said I'm not going to tell
you what I told President Xi or talk to
him about in regard to the laboratory
but it does sort of indicate that there
may have been a conversation there